[Applause]
[Music]
I actually know why you're happy today
for real though because finally somebody
nice way ahead of me but you know what
I'm gonna say who was treated to this
country's actually in jail poor man
the law judge said they should lock him
up lock him up even worse news Kim
Kardashian is not taking his calls so is
he gonna get a part at this Trump said
about man afraid he had nothing to do
with the campaign nothing to do with the
campaign yeah exactly you personally
brought him in you gave him the title
campaign chairman yeah that's just
that's just something we told him it
it's like when they told Elvis he and a
black belt it wasn't really so much
happened this so much legal stuff
happened this week finally after 18
months of working on this the the
Justice Department's inspector general
released his report on the FBI's actions
in the 2016 election Trump said he
wanted to read the whole thing before
commenting I'm joking of course
it's 500 pages he gets bored halfway
through a fortune cookie the upshot of
it is that the FBI helped Trump as we
all knew and Trump made such a big deal
out of Hillary's emails that Comey
didn't want anyone to think that the FBI
was helping Hillary and was on her side
so they rat-fucked her campaign you know
it's like when the wrath needs to show
that he's fair he shoots the hometown
quarterback in the mouth
and Michael Cohen did you hear this
Trump fixer Lauria whatever want to call
them
it's lap dog he's there saying I don't
know if this is true this thing he's
ready to cooperate with prosecutors I
hope that makes Trump nervous I mean
Michael Cohen has given more money to
porn stars than Charlie Sheen took out a
restraining order on Michael a vanetti
right wanting to stop appearing on
television the complaint I love this
says I'm a nanny is creating a circus
with his unquestioned question
unquenchable thirst for publicity
Michael you do know you work for Donald
Trump that's good but and also listen to
this New York's Attorney General has
filed a lawsuit trying to shut down
Trump's family's phony charity
what they say is persistent illegal
conduct it was basically a slush fund
which they used as an arm of the
campaign they were funneling money to
some of the least deserving charities in
the world Doctors Without Borders got a
real charity st. Barts Children's
Hospital that's ridiculous
so with all these schedules you know
whose poll numbers are sinking like a
rock not Donald Trump's his are up
people who are sinking or anyone in the
Republican Party who crosses Donald
Trump remember Mark Sanford from South
Carolina the guy who was hiking the
Appalachian Trail is really having an
affair with an Argentinian woman he was
like in the Appalachian Trail all right
but you know he votes with Trump
seventy-three percent of the time it
said a few critical thing
outs he didn't win his primary cuz he
had he survived he was reelected after
having sex with the Argentinian woman
but Trump banks porn stars right here in
the USA ladies and gentlemen one reason
Trump's numbers are up of course he has
a new friend King Jimmy Jean I know it
seems like years ago it was only the
beginning of this week they had their
big summit Trump cannot stop talking
about what a great guy Kim is he's a
great negotiator yeah yeah we found that
out he's got a great personality he says
he's a funny guy he said he's a funny
he's a funny guy
Kim there's a funny you know he does
this one bit you get off so funny where
he will throw three generations of your
family in jail if you're listening to a
radio that's not on the government
station it's just it's great stuff and
then he sings right into his bit about
how many North Korea does it take to
screw in a lightbulb none we have no
electricity
so Donald Trump is over there and tried
to convince Kim to whatever that would
try to do come into the modern world so
he shows him I couldn't make this up a
fake movie trailer that Trump put
together it looks like Kim put it
together
truck did you see this show a few
seconds of this you have to see it to
believe it
a new world can begin today what a
friendship respect and goodwill looks
like something Scientology would make if
they were merging with Amway Trump comes
up he's got the great beaches their
hotels yes because so many people in
that country have money to burn so they
begin to get a condo on the beach of
course and you know resort hotels in
North Korea are a little different you
look you call down to room service they
ask him you of any food
so and of course all the critics are
saying they're right you know nothing
really came of this it was two people
who lie about everything who signed a
deal that was specific about nothing I
would say it was a feckless stunt but
while he was in Singapore the president
passed a milestone he turned 72 years
old they Trump people are welcome insane
but welcome but they throw him a big
party in the hotel suite and then the
hookers peed happy birthday on the back